[Music]
hello everybody today's topic of this
podcast is the impact of social media on
high schoolers and I say high schoolers
specifically because even though I'm
sure that social media has had an impact
on people of every generation like if
you're alive today and you're under 60
years old you probably at least know
what it is but I also think that it's
more important to talk about the effects
of it on the mental health of young
people because we've been exposed to it
a lot more than older
generations and we are going to
experience the long terms of it so see
what the effects of it are in the long
run what whereas they aren't which is
why it's more important to talk about
the the effects of it on younger
people anyway um obviously I'm a young
person I'm a high schooler so throughout
this whole podcast I will be speaking
from personal
experience um because I am an avid
social media user which is not something
that I'm the most proud of but it is
what it
is um and I have consciously and
subconsciously weighed the pros and cons
of social media many many times in my
head I have tried
many things many ways to convince myself
to get off apps and do my work because
let's be honest half the time social
media is just a distraction from The
Real
World but I can't say that it doesn't
have a lot of Pros I mean social media
is what keeps us in loop with others
it's what keeps us updated on knowledge
it's just it's what keeps us
maintain a connection that we wouldn't
otherwise have but is this really a good
thing because what I have noticed is
that a lot of uh connections that are
created and maintained using means of
social media are more superficial than
real life connections
and because they're so easily accessible
you have interactions with people that
you don't even know at the click of a
button it takes away from real life
interactions it makes people want to
have real life interactions less that is
one of the cons and I think that is a
really big cun in my generation I
personally I have online
friends but it's just not the
same as having real friends it's not the
same listen I use my online friends for
one thing you know they're good for
talking to but they can't compare to
real friends that people you talk to in
real life you will always get
more meaningful things out of them more
meaningful words you will always have a
deeper connection with with
them but that's just that's not all of
it that is more so the connection part
of social media because how I see social
media is in two three categories the
first one is connection with friends or
connection with people so when you look
at the main social media platforms like
Instagram Snapchat Tik to all of them
you they all have like uh compartments
where you message people the messaging
compartments the texting compartments
and that's just where you talk to people
that's one of the main obviously
the like purposes of social media the
second one is just entertainment
entertainment purposes consuming
information consuming content and the
third one is posting
content so I think the most potent
category of those three is the consuming
entertainment one and I think it is the
most problematic I heard once a while
ago that um social media algorithms are
purposely designed to keep you addicted
to them and purposely designed to keep
you scrolling through them endlessly
because I cannot say how many times I
have been just scrolling mindlessly
through my f you page through my uh
explore page whatever when I have had so
much work that needed to be done and I
would love to blame it all on the
algorithm the way it's made but honestly
it's also just me not owning up to the
fact that I have a lot of work to do and
I feel like it's like that for a lot of
people because when I talk to my friends
about this subject they're all like oh
you know I had homework to do I had to
study for this test I had an assignment
to do I was supposed to do it yesterday
the day before whatever I couldn't
because I was just mindlessly scrolling
through my for you page consuming
unnecessary
information I can't can't say I have
I've learned a lot of things from just
scrolling I've learned things that I
would never know otherwise but these
things are not as useful as they should
be they're not
worth the time you could be putting into
actual work the time you could be
putting into your friends and family the
time you could be putting into doing
things you love it's
entertainment but it's cheap one uh
phrase I heard was that it's it's it's
kind of just a cheap dopamine hit it
hits at your dopamine it Digs at it it
gives you like you know hits of
dopamine but there it's not dopamine
that you had to work for because it's so
easily accessible everybody can AC
access it and everybody has access it to
it
24/7 and that's why it's cheap because
you don't have to work for it dopamine
activities that you do have to work for
for example
hobbies and even school work I would
consider that a dopamine hit because if
you put a lot of effort into an
assignment and then your teacher Praises
you for it that gives you a dopamine hit
that you actually worked for and that's
a healthy dopamine hit and that's what
we all strive to look
for but you know I'm using this as an
example to say that social media is
just designed to keep you addicted
designed to keep you on the platform I'm
not sure if that's how it originally was
created like from the very start um but
I am 100% sure that as it gained
popularity more and more people started
to be addicted to that entertainment
category and
uh referencing
the the content posting category that
can also have some very bad effects on
people because one thing I noticed is
that a lot of people my age get
validation from posting on social media
and it's not good validation because
half the time the things not even half
the time most of the time the things
that they post on social media
are very much altered they they don't
reflect their real life which is fine
there is no judgment in that I'm not
judging this at all um because I can't
say that I haven't done it either
but it's just an altered
altered polished up version of
themselves that doesn't exist in real
life and they get validation from
something that doesn't really exist
which will never be good validation and
they will never feel fulfilled with
themselves or satisfied with with
themselves from this type of validation
which is why I think it's so harmful
especially when you see all these
influencers all these uh popular content
creators and they post things that don't
reflect their real lives at all they
post photos of themselves and that's not
not what they look like they post their
life but it's only the good parts of it
and not the bad parts and then everybody
everybody thinks to themselves whether
they would admit it or not why can't my
life look like theirs why can't I look
like them why can't I do what they're
doing how is it they have such a good
life and I don't but that's never the
reality ever like I can guarantee that
most people who post on social media and
have some kind of big following or
mediocre following nothing that they
post reflects their real life and I know
this because I've never once met a
person in my life that posted things
that reflect how they actually are in
real life because the only reason why we
post on social media um if it's not like
for education purposes or you know if
it's merely just to get validation it's
never going to be something that
reflects the real you because you want
validation and I I just assume that
nobody
feels not it's not that nobody feels
good enough it's
[Music]
just